c'est incroyable on l'a rajouté parce
que c'est c'est Jacques Legros donc
effectivement je sais pas s'il y a une
photo avec le gros il y avait pas de jeu
là dessus donc il a sorti un livre qui
s'appelle derrière l'écran et il parle
de Jean-Pierre Pernaut dans ce livre
Jean-Pierre Pernaut vous le savez qui
est qui est mort il y a pas très
longtemps voici la première citation de
ce qu'ils disent sur Jean-Pierre Pernaut
ah on l'a pas mon chou tu me l'as pas
marqué
ah ça se voit que là tu les as toi
c'est pas tu me l'as dit c'est une
panacloc sur salut
[Applaudissements]
attention il voulait de plus en plus
prendre la main sur l'ensemble du
journal je commençais à bouillir
intérieurement jusqu'au jour où j'ai
éclaté
puisqu'il voulait faire le journal à ma
place qu'il vienne le faire et qu'il me
laisse tranquille première citation
je vous en donne une deuxième attention
vas-y deuxième
il voulait garder tout le temps le
premier rôle
solliciter l'équipe plus que nécessaire
point la ligne dernière citation on aura
fait le tour c'était la dernière merci
beaucoup voilà pour les citations donc
il sera un bouquin on rappelle le
contexte le gros qui est le joker de tes
de gens quand il est en vacances
historiquement fait le remplacement
total de Jean-Pierre quand il est malade
et qu'il doit rester chez lui pendant
les confinement etc et il se trouve que
donc Jacques fait le journal et
Jean-Pierre garder une grosse place à la
fin du journal et c'est des places 15
minutes une place et que c'est dans ce
cadre là que Jacques Legros répond ça il
a ajouté aussi que pendant le
confinement leur lien se sont vraiment
distendus et qui et qui ne se parlaient
plus donc voilà déjà juste avant ça
est-ce qu'on peut critiquer ou pas une
personne est-ce qu'il fallait pas le
faire avant maintenant qu'il est mort
mais évidemment Nathalie Marquay a
répondu et là on a la réponse avec
raison
est-ce que tu t'es dit quand tu as vu
cet article et ce passage du livre de
Jacques Legros moi personnellement
Nathalie j'ai halluciné
et surtout que Monsieur Jacques Legros
oublie qu'il n'était que son joker et il
se permet de se plaindre qu'à cette
époque JP veut garder la main sur le
contenu du journal mais c'est qui depuis
plus de 30 ans qui a donné le ton du
Trésor et à qui on attribue attribuer
les résultats d'audience aussi et de
plus Jacques Legros lui faisait des
coups de [ __ ] si je peux le dire
excusez-moi parce que oui parce que
pendant pendant confinement donc il
faisait des sujets et au démarrage
Jean-Pierre il devait avoir 15 minutes
d'antenne et après Jacques Legros chaque
fois il faisait de plus en plus des
sujets très très longs c'est à dire que
vers la fin après il est resté plus que
6 minutes d'antenne et moi j'étais un
peu jaloux un peu écrit avec le gros
justement moi je trouve que ça ressemble
vraiment à de la jolie à de la jalousie
post mortem
effectivement il n'était pas amis mais
JP le respecter beaucoup en tant que
collègues et en plus il l'a souvent
défendu auprès de TF1 et comme ça je
termine Jacques le gros à re répandu et
il a dit je soutiens mes propos j'ai pas
attendu tout ce temps pour lisser mon
récit qu'est-ce que vous pensez de tout
cette histoire Florian pour le coup je
suis d'accord avec Nathalie Marquay et
et pour une raison assez simple c'est
qu'en fait Jacques Legros n'a jamais pu
réellement blairer Jean-Pierre Pernaut
je pense que c'est de notoriété
relativement public en tout cas on peut
le dire et au moment des obsèques de
Jean-Pierre Pernaut il y a quelques mois
il a donné quelques interviews parce que
forcément c'était son joker et dans ces
interviews notamment une au parisiens
qu'il avait donné il distille est déjà
des petites balles alors il le disait
avec un peu de tendresse quand même mais
il disait grosso modo ce qu'on a raconté
là avec un petit peu plus de forme donc
là il a juste changé la forme mais le
fond est le même et il disait il disait
souvent les deux que c'était deux gars
du Nord mais c'était deux gars du Nord
qui s'aimaient pas trop mais qui c'était
qui s'aiment pas on l'a bien compris
mais est-ce que ça se fait tout d'un
coup de sortir ça maintenant qu'il est
plus là
de de parler de quelqu'un qui n'est plus
de ce monde paix à son âme peu importe
les conflits qu'on a pu avoir parlé de
quelqu'un qui n'est plus là il avait
qu'à lui dire en face quand il était là
après ma mort moi je te l'ai dit
non mais vraiment je trouve ça honteux
c'est nul de régler ses comptes une fois
que la personne est plus de ce monde je
trouve ça naze voilà je suis désolé de
ne manquer de respecter
bah oui parce que déjà je trouve ça
humain et je pense que tout le monde le
ferait d'être de vouloir être premier
qu'on est Joker officiel qu'on fait des
très bonnes audiences que quand il
remplacer Jean-Pierre Pernaut les
audiences de chutaient pas il maintenait
quand même le navire à flot il faisait
toujours des très bonnes audiences donc
même on nous on aurait pu leur projet
pas vouloir prendre être numéro 1 quand
il était numéro 2 ça aurait un manque
d'ambition qui était qui était je trouve
un défaut et après ben on peut parler
des morts voilà ça veut pas dire qu'on
est pas capable on peut pas on peut
parler on parle à longueur de temps des
gens qui sont morts voilà après Sophie
il y a sûrement une question de timing
aussi par exemple si tu dis bon ben
voilà Yves Montand était comme si ou je
sais pas où Claude François était un
connard et par les mal à tout le monde
bon il y a quand même une petite
question de timing il y a sa veuve qui a
encore en deuil il est mort il y a pas
longtemps je trouve que c'est une
question pose une question pour Laurent
qui a connu beaucoup d'animateurs en
fait très honnête quand même de parler
du débat de Père Noël
et non je parle pas sur Paris je me suis
pris des tutos
je pars pas sur panneau qu'on soit un
petit poney sur quelque chose est-ce que
quelqu'un connaît ici un animateur star
et phare Père Noël de Chavanne euh
Ardisson sympa à New York
cette année mais qu'il soit pas de
Chavanne extrêmement caractériel et un
peu dictatorial
donc je pense que Pernaut n'était pas un
gentil ça n'arriverait un pantalon
il était gentil mais
quand on dit tout à l'heure il attend sa
mort pour balancer je pense qu'ils sont
déjà engueulés et Jean-Pierre des
dizaines de fois
vous croyez que Jacques Martin était
sympa était sympa
il y a quelques mecs sympas
non mais un mec un mec comme par exemple
Denis Brogniart je pense qu'il y a pas
une seule personne de se tromper
je crois qu'on va tourner Brognard va on
va on va lancer la pub et sur un truc
mais il te règle le truc direct derrière
dans la dans la loge et c'est fini et
après et après il est pas rancunier non
il est pas rancunier et après c'est
reparti est toujours là pour toi au
final exactement
c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
c'est un bon gars